all right so there was a hearing
yesterday really over the last couple of
days and uh secretary of defense lloyd
austin was questioned by members of
congress uh the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark milley was
questioned and this
hearing
was the epitome
of showboating
and grandstanding to no benefit
whatsoever of the american people full
stop there's barely more of an
there's almost no additional analysis to
do
other than many of these members of
congress really have no business being
in congress and you'll very quickly
figure out which individuals those are
much of the hearing was meant to
just provide a cartoonish opportunity
for people like matt gates and others to
demand and or request
that general mark milley uh resign and
they couched it as being related to
afghanistan although the topic of mark
milley having to sort of
reassure china that trump is not going
to just bomb you in the last few days of
his presidency
uh that's a story that we we learned
about as a result
of this uh book by uh carol lennog and
philip brucker i believe it is uh let's
just get right into the clips it's
really amazing here is uh congressman
joe wilson
who calls for president joe biden to
resign just countless calls for
resignations during these hearings bucks
stops with 13 murdered marines mr biden
the gentleman's disregarding the
military advice and i believe the
president should resign
i'm prepared to begin my questions i
believe the president should resign
everybody should resign according to
these hearings
then and this is actually really
important milly actually explains
what it was that led him to
communicate with chinese officials in
those final days of the trump presidency
and congressman hartzler republican from
missouri says milly should resign look
at this many others
that the chinese thought wrongly
that the united states is going to
attack them i am certain
guaranteed certain that president trump
had no intent to attack and it was my
task to make sure i communicated that
and the purpose was to de-escalate
you shared all that earlier
understanding
just say did you or did you sorry and i
think i said congressman hartzler it's
congresswoman hearts laura i think i
misspoke before
ask tell him that if we were going to
attack you would let him know as part of
that conversation i said generally
there's not going to be a war there's
not going to be attack between great
powers and if there was the tensions
would build up there'd be calls going
back and forth from all kinds of senior
officials i said hell generally i'll
probably give you a call but we're not
going to attack you trust me we're not
going to attack you these are two great
powers and i am doing my best to
transmit the president's intent
so understand that the right wants to
frame what millie did as some kind of
treason by calling china and saying
we're not going to attack you no matter
what which then would be a signal to
china hey the u.s isn't going to attack
us no matter what now it's a carte
blanche for us to do stuff what milly is
explaining is he called and he said
listen in these last few days
trump's not going to just start dropping
random bombs on you if we were going to
get into a military conflict there would
be an escalation we would be talking the
way that things happened there would be
threats there would be an escalation
that is obviously not the treason that
the right one wants to make it out to be
but hartzler doesn't care it's intent to
ensure that the american people are
protected from an incident that could
escalate
i understand your intent but i think you
articulating that that you would tell
him you would give him a call i think is
worthy of your resignation
um i just think that's against our
country that you would give our number
one adversary
that information and tell him that these
people they're either idiots or they're
pretending but there is
it it's
there there's just nothing there there's
i don't know how else to say it then
matt gates gets involved then it gets
even more embarrassing february 26 2020
house armed services committee general
mark milley
we know we're not going to defeat the
taliban militarily and they're not going
to defeat the government of afghanistan
militarily
you really blew that call didn't you
general
i believe that that was a
issue of strategic stalemate and that if
we had remained in afghanistan
uh with the advisory levels of effort
than the government of afghanistan
that's that's an interesting answer to a
question it's just not one i asked you
spent more time with bob woodward on
this book than you spent analyzing the
very likely prospect that the
afghanistan government was going to fall
immediately to the taliban didn't you
not even close congressman oh really
because you said right after kabul fell
that no one could have anticipated the
immediate fall of the ghani government
when did you become aware that joe biden
tried to get ghani to lie about the
conditions in afghanistan he did that in
july did you know that right away
i'm not aware of
what president biden
you're not aware of the phone call that
biden had with gani where he said
whether it is true or not we want you to
go out there and paint a rosy picture of
what's going on in afghanistan you're
the chief military adviser to the
president you said that the taliban was
not going to defeat the government of
afghanistan militarily which by the way
they cut through them like a hot knife
through butter it was just endlessly
like this just gates is is horrible
and then gates mentions as an aside that
biden is too addled to even fire anyone
uh but that they should be
uh they shouldn't be in their positions
it it just it gets crazy but
you said yesterday that you weren't
going to resign when senators asked you
this question
and i believe that you guys probably
won't resign you seem to be
very happy failing up over there
but if we didn't have a president that
was so adult
you all would be fired because that is
what you deserve you have let down the
people who wear the uniform in my
district and all around this country and
you're far more interested in what your
perception is and how people think about
you and insider washington books than
you care about winning because this time
has been capable of doing
miss wilhelm is recognized
thank you mr chair and gentlemen i
apologize for the behavior of my
colleague
it's just grandstanding this this does
nothing to move forward the interests of
the american people or of the united
states as a country globally
um in this next clip um donald trump's
former doctor ronnie jackson who's now a
member of congress
also uh getting millie completely
exasperated
general milly will you now resign
i serve at the pleasure of the president
mr jackson
[Laughter]
um congressman pat fallon from texas
uh asking milly about his comments about
that horribly botched drone strike in
afghanistan
and uh of course taking them completely
out of context and uh general milley on
september first three days later you
described it as a righteous strike
people that were not supposed to be
killed were killed and you described it
as a righteous strike
yeah if you go back and look at the full
quote what i said was we followed the
procedures
uh i had every reason to believe that um
that we followed our procedures at that
point in time we knew that there were
civilians killed we knew there were
non-combatants and there was uh
collateral yes you said were others
killed yes who are they we don't know
we're trying to sort through all that
right that's right i said that's right
because i believed kill people we should
know i believe it was right i believe
that the target that we were aiming at
sir and i believe the target
was okay i have three more and uh and
this is a strategy which is you don't
even really give time to answer the
questions now i think i've already
spoken about the botched drone strike
and it's absolutely horrifying and
disgusting but the idea that suddenly
republicans care about drone strikes and
civilian deaths is laughable and then
last clip here's the previous day this
is senator tom cotton again bringing up
what why haven't there been resignations
it's got one final question general
milley i can only conclude
that your advice
about staying in afghanistan was
rejected i'm shocked to learn that your
advice wasn't sought until august 25th
on staying past the august 31 deadline
i understand that you're the principal
military advisor that you advise you
don't decide the president decides
but if all this is true general milly
why haven't you resigned
senator
as a senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing
that's a political act if i'm resigning
in protest my job is to provide advice
my statutory responsibilities provide
legal advice or best military advice to
the president and that's my legal
requirement so millie having to explain
to tom cotton sort of like how things
work we learned nothing from these
hearings what is the dollar value the
dollar cost of these hearings
to just allow these republicans to ask
why haven't you resigned essentially
without an interest even in learning
anything
about what has actually taken place just
more pathetic behavior by this modern
republican party one of our sponsors is
atlas vpn in the year 2021 many computer
security experts say everybody everybody
should be using a vpn whenever you
connect to the internet atlas vpn keeps
your information private from big tech
companies from your internet service
provider even from governments atlas vpn
helps you stay protected from hackers
trying to steal your data an atlas vpn
even lets you watch shows and movies on
netflix and other streaming services you
would otherwise only be able to access
from other countries i use atlas vpn on
all of my devices phone computer tablet
whenever i'm connected to the internet
it's so easy to use you sign up install
it turn it on and you're done out of
sight out of mind you stay protected and
right now my audience can get atlas vpn
for a dollar 39 a month
with a 30 day money back guarantee you
just have to go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video